he is uh in uh season two uh
season two of uh amazon prime videos
the boys he is back here on the rich
eisen show
he is actor chase crawford how are you
sir
how you guys doing man good to be here
good to see you how's life what's going
on in your world
it's good you know uh uh you know
world's on fire a little bit over here
in
california but it's good i'm uh i'm up
here in idaho just just hanging out
season two daring and
we're having a good time fantastic again
the first four episodes of season two
are available right now on amazon prime
video and we will discuss that
in a second if i'm not mistaken you did
grow up a dallas cowboys fan correct
chase do we have this kind of thing
i digress with dallas cowboys fan okay
so from the great state of idaho were
you watching sunday
night football this week from uh from i
am i've been watching almost every game
it's good
it's good to have it back yeah i watched
kc thursday night we watched a couple on
uh
on sunday night out here and uh yeah
chicago's come back the whole thing okay
jen are you concerned about the dallas
cowboys start of the 2020 season chase
crawford you're concerned at all
you know uh a little bit a little bit uh
i was i'm i'm an are you saying as well
i was wanting to see some cd lamb out
there
okay uh you know um let's see what
mccarthy's gonna bring to it uh
you know i know there's a questionable
call there but uh
yeah we'll see how the we'll see how
this even plays out well uh it was it
was rough you went higher register to
start
that uh comment right there and here on
the rich eisen show when you go higher
register you don't really believe
what you're saying um
kind of on a higher register with that
voice of yours chase to start
so it's it's it sometimes can be tough
being a cowboys fan you know so
yeah i might i'm a little skeptical uh
you know underneath just being
happy that this football's even back at
all but i'll definitely be watching
every week and uh
yeah the rams look good though you know
the rams look like they're you know
from a couple years ago so you know okay
yeah it could be their 2020 season and
when you would talk about
uh oklahoma football my god kylo murray
looked phenomenal
this is phenomenal i'm definitely i'm
definitely a kind of a side
bandwagon cardinals fan he looked
absolutely amazing so i got him on my
fantasy team this year
you do okay by the way
so do i so does chris brockman across
the way
we are all in on kyler murray i will say
this because
um like for instance i don't usually
bring up um
takes if you will or opinions that i
have that are wrong okay i don't usually
bring those up like for instance
the fact that i said that the clippers
would win the nba title just about a
week ago i don't usually bring that up
but you know
just just for you know i guess
currency's sake i'll bring that up
but i did say after the season just
after last season just after the kansas
city chiefs won the super bowl that i
thought kyler murray would be top three
in the mvp voting this year and i
am particularly pleased to see what what
happened in week one just on that front
alone
he's on track he's on track i mean he's
uh
you know you never know with some of
these guys coming coming straight in
from uh
from college and obviously his size he's
just so quick and he's
he's incredible so uh he got some
weapons down there and um
yeah i'm definitely i'm definitely you
know watching watching the cardinals on
the side
so who else do you have on your fantasy
team
uh who else do i got we got uh i mean
look
unfortunately i've got obj on the
fantasy football team you know we
we kind of got hosed on the uh snake
draft we were last up so you know you
get you get two
two picks about every about every 30
picks so we kind of had to
kind of had to go with what with what we
had so um
yeah we lost week one but uh you know we
got
uh we got mixing uh kittle okay you know
sony michelle you know uh
not not not the greatest i think we got
about a c minus on the draft
on the draft score is that the name of
your fantasy team name c minus is that
the name
it might as well be what is your fantasy
team name what is it
oh it's called the bread basket yeah we
uh we i co
i co-manage with a buddy who lives in
new york which makes a little more fun
the bread basket's won though twice in
the past uh five years so
uh you know usually usually we pull it
out but
is that a bread basket is that in
reference to where your brother-in-law
keeps his money is that what that is
no but that's a great that's a great
gift that's a good gift idea first next
birthday i would i just
you know i'll get i'll get him a golden
bread basket now i think he's already
got a uh
chase you know i think he's you know i'm
trying to sit here i love my
brother-in-law i love him
i'm wondering if he if i ever get a
phone call from him saying hey guess
what i'm making now a year
i and that would be it i mean what was
that like uh
for you chase to hear that from romo
or your sister you know i i i i
nothing shocks me anymore with him only
he could go and and kind of seamlessly
ease into
uh the position that he was doing i mean
the funny thing is he used to do that
after games he would love to
even win her loss and record it and and
sometimes you know we'd have we'd go
back to the house a bunch of friends and
family and just kind of
set everyone down and then you know
midway through and he had a little
pointer actually and he would break down
a few
like the key plays the game record or
whatever and he would just talk about it
we were
blown away you talk about a play for 10
minutes you know that it's like a four
second play and
and so i was never really that surprised
when he was you know his football iq up
there and then being so good at it but
to
to get to get the money you got you know
getting getting quarterback money up
there
we're really we're really we're really
proud of it you should be
you should be i i was hosting a chalk
talk as they call
it um prior to super bowl 50
in san francisco um where
uh you know a a corporate entity uh
invites a couple of players
uh either active or former
to deliver an x's no speech to the to
the
the gathered crowd steve young and tony
romo
was uh the other one and um when tony
started talking
and doing his thing i turned to steve
and i gave him a look
and he gave me a look and he just nodded
his head and like the look was
essentially like
this is what he's going to do when he
stops playing like that was yeah it was
obvious from the first second so i guess
my question for you is
having dinner with him or thanksgiving
dinner with him
um does he call what people are about to
do before they do it uh to grab the fork
or pass something does he is that what
he is that he does even just
off air too he knew i was mixing the
potatoes with the corn right before it
happened and it was pretty
yeah it was uh it was amazing and we're
just getting used to it
you know he's got that crystal ball
somewhere i love it
are you a better player are you a better
golfer than him chase i know you played
in high school are you a better golfer
than tony romo your brother that would
be false that would be false i
i golf with him uh quite a bit actually
he
yeah i mean he's he's always teaching me
some new thing but but
but get this i mean he kind of he
injured his wrist we played i
played about two three weeks ago in
dallas and uh i get out there
and i'm like tony are you swinging the
club with one hand he's like yeah i've
been playing one-handed
come on i'm like get get out of here
he's playing he played 18 holes right
handed and and beat the pants off man
he's still he can still hit he can still
hit a drive down the middle
about 280 with with one come on come on
come on
so hold on a second chase crawford here
on the rich eyes and [ __ ] we'll talk
about the boys
in a second so you're saying he said
he's taking his stance
over his ball and he just
settles in maybe with both hands because
you know
uh that's the way he's set up or did he
just
really never use his left hand because
he's it's injured in some way shape or
form
he wasn't touching it he wasn't touching
the club with his left with his with his
left hand he would chip he was saying he
would keep a chip with him but even
even out of the bunkers he was doing
one-handed i'm not i'm not even kidding
i don't know what his exact final score
was but he destroyed me
with one hand that is ridiculous that's
absurd
that's absurd yeah he's he's pretty good
he's always you know he's always been in
scratch but he's
uh he he's a good coach too he can talk
about it for hours of course i mean
he's a communicator so okay so he's a
scratch golfer with one hand
which is absurd uh what about your game
um what's the best round you've ever had
oh struggling i think i i
i was better in high school and i've
been practicing quite a bit i can't do
what he does and take you know
you know a month off and come back and
shoot even part i think i shot about
even par
i shot 71 when i was in when i was in
high school that was my best round i
would
touch the high 70s mid 70s sometimes
now about i'm about low 80s low to mid
80s depending on uh
depending on the uh on the course but uh
i i think i heard someone say shot 123
at wingfoot yeah that's that's
that's me that was me that's you i was
123 a congressional before
before they cut the rough uh prior to
the us open that year
that's what i shot um yeah and by the
way chase i was using both hands
exactly i used both hands to shoot that
i mean that is an absurd story
did you play with anybody that we might
know of i mean if you're playing high
school in texas
i mean it's entirely possible you might
have been playing against or with
somebody significant
in the sport no no i didn't but i was
still pretty young i think my sister and
tony were still dating i go back
you know to their house and hang and he
we used to live on you know las colinas
that uh
fire nelson course anyway we we he we
take a golf cart out and he was like
son's going down he's like hey we're
meeting this we're meeting this kid you
know he's a wizard around the greens i
mean he's like
got to go to texas he's 17. he's just
you know we're going to play six holes
and he's pretty cool jordan speed
you know and you know jordan speech
shows up and he's like texas bag and
he's 17 and yeah he's like
pulling out chips and you know so i've i
got i've got to play with with jordan a
few times over the years and he's uh
he's a great dude we're we're all fans
of uh the texas guy scotty shuffler my
buddy will zeletorus who's going to be
playing u.s open this weekend and uh
yeah so um looking forward to seeing
those guys out there
i'm looking forward to seeing the us
open as well tell me about the boys on
amazon prime video chase and know what
you what you like about it what you've
enjoyed being
a part of for this yeah i know the
show's great we see that we shoot up in
toronto it's season two now it's um
you know it's it's you think going into
it watching it's like kind of a typical
superhero show but it's
it's not it's pretty it's pretty bizarre
it's pretty out there my character's
uh a little bit of a you know satirical
aquaman
zoolander almost in a way and uh you
know
we're making we're making fun of the
fish guy you know and uh
it's it's been it's been a lot of fun
it's been dark there's some comedic
elements and the
cast is fantastic season two i think is
even better than season one uh
creator aircraft he did such a good job
with it and uh we're looking forward to
going back in january
for season three okay how does how does
how does one
prepare to play somebody who can breathe
underwater how do you do something like
that chase
you know i thought i was going to be in
the water a lot more you know because
i'm wearing basically a wetsuit onesie
and
that wasn't that wasn't the case they
put the characters in like the therapist
office and you know yeah
it's uh it's hilarious a little bit
uh of a character you know
character-driven story art but uh
you know not not not not too much to
prep uh you know they put me in the
tight sleeveless thing i
hit the gym a little more and that was
about it so by the way if uh if bread
basket
starts to um starts to falter maybe you
should rename your team wetsuit onesie
that wouldn't be bad
you could do that wetsuit onesie you
know what the avatar would be
that's great i love that yeah i try to
make you better when you call in
you know what i mean than when i found
you hey chase uh congrats on season two
of the boys on amazon prime video and
congrats on it being renewed for season
three already that's
that's uh that's great news and i always
appreciate the chat uh best
that's to you and yours thank you man
thanks for having me it's great talking
to you always that's chase crawford
it's uh that's his uh moniker on twitter
and instagram
chase with two c's crawford at chase
crawford
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here